Charlie au rapport Charlie en position
bien reçu team leader en
position laisse-moi descendre
C tu bouges pas c'est
compris
sur touch on les a touch pas vrai
non
[Musique]
tiens tiens tiens regardez-moi un peu
tout ce beau
monde mon argent
interpo ça peut pas être une coïncidence
on arrête tout tant qu'on sait pas qui
est la
taupe c'est un ami de papa tu
connaissais mon vrai papa c'est un
fantôme de ton passé ça doit être dur de
rentrer chez soi et de ne plus rien
avoir à défendre il y a toujours quelque
chose à
[Musique]
défendre asseez-vous alors que se
passe-t-il où sont passés mes 15
de million d'euros ce sera réglé demain
sans faute fini les
complications c'est Paul Woodley à
l'appareil on devrait faire affaire vous
êtes censé surveiller mon argent oui je
comprends mais il y a eu une autre
complication je vous ai dit que j'aimais
pas les complications tiens je t'ai fait
un
dessin
lâchemoi
est dans
[Applaudissements]
voiture est
la il je vous avais dit qu'il me fallait
du
temps je vais tous les tuer tout ce que
je veux c'est récupérer je F tout ce que
vous voudrez vous allez m'orter ça si
jamais vous me mentez je butterai chaque
membre de votre
familleù est
la
débarrasse
[Musique]
G